AdWords allows you to create ads
that are designed especially for
mobile users.
With the prevalence of mobile users
across the world, optimizing for
ads on mobile is a great way
to acquire new customers.
There are a ton of options on AdWords
to appeal to your customers on mobile
including text ads,
image ads, app promotions,
call only ads, not to mention all the
other ad options you have within actual
apps on different phones and tablet's.
Now, think about your audience
when determining what type of
ad you want to use.
Think about where they are when
they're viewing your ad.
For example, people seeing your ads on
mobile are more likely to want to know
where you are and how to call you, so
you can consider using a text
ad to show your location and
your phone number, with location
extensions and call extensions.
Or you can use a call only ad, which
will include a call button in your ad.
Now think about it,
when you're looking for Starbucks and
you search the term on your
mobile phone, how easy is it to
click on the location extension and
go directly to your nearest Starbucks?
Also creating ads devoted to
people on mobile devices.
For example, using the mobile version
of your website as your landing page.
And your regular text ads may
appear differently on mobile.
So keep that in mind when
you're designing them.
Check out the instructor notes for
more information on that.
One perk of Image ads, is you don't
actually need to change anything on
mobile, except a link
to your mobile site.
These ads are the same ads that
are going to show up on your desktop.
You just want to make sure you're
linking to the right landing page.
However, you're going to need to opt in
to the display network in your settings.
Or search network with display selected.
We'll talk more about
display networks later.
App promotion ads, or also known as
click to download ads, are one of
the best ways to get your app downloaded
easily and efficiently for customers.
These are designed to show up on
devices that will have the most impact.
So you're not going to see these
popping up on your desktop.
Determining the right options for you
is all about knowing your audience and
what devices they're going to be using.
So you can design your
ads appropriately.